Speaker 1: I want to start today by talking about
how lying became acceptable in American politics.
You know, we've talked about George Santos over
the last several weeks. We've seen the lies of
so many Republicans in the context of the House
speaker fiasco. And it's just layers and layers
and layers. And, of course, we saw four years
of Donald Trump and the amount of dishonesty
that was that was there. It is unfortunately
true that lying has become acceptable in this
sense that it does not significantly damage a
politician or can that its chances of winning
elected office. While it's generally understood
like, oh, lying is bad in some cultural sense,
we still sort of look down at lying. Politicians
regularly lie or mislead the public without really
suffering significant consequences. And in fact,
in some cases politicians have been able to win
elections after being caught in really, really bad
lies. How did this come to be? One reason for this
is that it's become easier for politicians to get
away with lying because of the proliferation of
news sources and the spread of misinformation
on social media, it can actually be tougher
for the average person who's busy working to
sort through all of the information and determine
what's true and what is not true, which means
that politicians can make false statements and
have them spread quickly, even if they're later
debunked and often avoid any consequences. The
political climate is increasingly divisive and
partizan and politicians might feel pressured to
lie in order to win or to advance their agendas.
They may feel that the ends justify the means and
that lying is a necessary part of the game. And it
seems as though many voters agree with that. That
same partizanship and polarization I've talked
about it before is, you know, we see ourselves
as fighting a war here. And even if the battle is
lost in the sense that we made stuff up, it's for
the greater good of winning this war. And so when
you have the politicians willing to do it and the
voters unwilling to punish for it, you get what
is essentially acceptable lying. It's important
for citizens to hold politicians accountable
for the things they say and the things they do,
and to demand transparency and honesty. And it
would be really difficult to completely eliminate
lying in politics. But we have a situation right
now where voters are as welcoming as ever of lies.
If they further what those voters already believe
should be what our elected officials are doing.
Many examples of like pretty big lies in history.
And we can talk about some of them. George H.W.
Bush. Remember the whole read my lips no new
taxes thing During his 88 presidential campaign,
he famously promised not going to raise taxes
in office. He signed a budget deal that included
tax increases. His broken promise was criticized,
but we could say the damage wasn't massive, even
though he did lose, Right? Ultimately, he did lose
in 1992 to Bill Clinton. Bill Clinton then said, I
did not have sexual relations with that woman. He
did. It was just a straight up lie. And although
it did lead to what we know, the investigation,
the impeachment, all this different stuff,
his approval rating really didn't suffer. And
ultimately he got himself reelected. So another
example and again, I'm not passing value
judgments on these. These are just examples
of lying essentially being acceptable.
Barack Obama, not everything Obama said
worked out to be true. And Barack Obama
said, if you like your health care plan,
you can keep it. This was during the debate around
the Affordable Care Act known as Obamacare. Let's
assume he meant it at the time or he wanted it to
be true. There are people who lost their health
care plans even though they like them, because
the new law made them invalid or non-compliant,
I think would be the way to say it. And there
was controversy around it. Republicans talked
about it. Barack Obama was reelected in 2012.
Now, there were so many other things going on,
we can't simply say he lied about that and then
got reelected. It's more complicated than that.
But we're building up this picture. And then with
Trump, it's quite literally thousands, thousands,
thousands of lies, some big, some small. Just to
pick a few different things. Trump's claims about
voter fraud in 2016, he said he actually won the
popular vote. He didn't. In 2020. He said he won
the election. He didn't major lie, absolutely huge
lie. His supporters just bought it. They believe
it. They. Aren't they didn't punish him for those
obvious lies. Trump's obvious lies about the size
of the inauguration crowd. Trump's claims about
coronavirus 15 cases will be zero and, you know,
inject bleach and all this different stuff.
Lies, dishonesty, etc.. So at the end of the day,
it's important for citizens to hold politicians
accountable for their words and for their actions.
And part of that has to be that it has to
be unacceptable to the voters to have the
level of lying and dishonesty that we have seen,
particularly from more recent leaders. The missing
link is as follows Voters are more willing
to overlook or excuse, lies and dishonesty
when politicians from their party are the ones
telling the lies. And this can happen out of a
sense of loyalty, out of a sense of, well, the
other side is way, way, way worse. And in the
highly partizan political climate that we have,
voters are already tending to seek out information
that supports their preexisting beliefs. This
is called confirmation bias that leads to the
spread of misinformation and it leads to
the acceptance or at minimum, at minimum,
the indifference to misleading statements, overt
lies as long as they align with your political
views. I try not to fall for this. And if I see
something that the left is saying that doesn't
make sense, I don't go with it, you know? I know
there's lots of people on the left who still say
GMO food is bad just by virtue of being GMO,
but I don't see the facts backing that up. I
don't see the studies in the science backing
that up, so I don't repeat it regardless of who
it is that's on one side or the other side of the
issue. It's a minor example, but it's an example
we should all be striving to do
that. And until that changes,
lying will continue to be a viable strategy
in American politics. What ultimately happens
with George Santos, where it's so extreme
and cartoonish, we don't know. We will see.